et la toile
alors là j'arrive y retrouver des
tocards hormones et paccard y en a c'est
la qualité prend personne et les
qualités humaines et professionnelles en
parler permet au quart numéro un dans
ses droits des tonga et bonjour le roi
des bons jours voilà une rebelle à l'on
compte les deux cas il y en a
à quoi cela veut dire à la caméra comme
dans mon petit coin là bas parce que là
tu vas encore très tôt car depuis les
noms jeudi jetant leurs après s'être
stock-car première fois qu'on s'est pas
vu au téléphone ils voulaient me taper
un faux pas non plus milité pour la
violence c'est super et parfois parade
face à la connerie est fière de toi ya
un trou noir rouge c'est bien non même
lotois mais jamais de rooney serait
comme kelly safra petit couple
le cinquième otage
[Musique]
ça s'est il senti les gars et une fois
que les garçons delaby bonne nouvelle je
rentre à de malades pas du tout les
passeurs en premier il nous chauffe le
plateau
bien la cuisine et istres et chaises
pour ces 4 430 3 2
oui ça fait vendre tout un peuple ou oui
bonjour je vous appelle parce que je
trouve qu'on va beaucoup trop benjamin
castaldi dans tpm paix dans le monde se
trouvent pas à six pattes ou on n'en
peut plus de benjamin castaldi on n'en
peut plus on est à bout on ira vannut
[Musique]
j
ça c'est le point quotidien avec marine
la femme quotidien et point quotidien
sans elle point seulement pour deux
c'est donc sur le shop et éthiques
les filles
[Musique]
m
cette saison en prêt
l'intuition et amy lee
[Musique]